mes chers collègues madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs notre commission d'enquête
entend aujourd'hui Madame Agnès panée
panier rue nachées ancienne ministre
délégué chargé de l'Industrie et
aujourd'hui ministre de la transition
énergétique madame la ministre vous avez
occupé pendant près de 4 ans le poste de
secrétaire d'État puis de ministre
délégué chargé de l'Industrie c'est
durant votre mandat ministériel que
c'est imposé dans le débat public la
notion souvent discutée de
relocalisation à la faveur d'une
revalorisation de l'image de l'industrie
mais surtout de la crise sanitaire du
covid-19 l'industrie pharmaceutique
française et ses choix passés ont été
mis en pleine lumière et discutées
durant la crise de la covid-19 vous avez
certainement pu comme nous constater les
dégâts laissés par près de 40 années de
désindustrialisation la France n'était
initialement pas en mesure de se
protéger et de soigner efficacement
contre le Sark Sark of 2 la faute
notamment à une trop forte dépendance
industrielle de notre pays tout le long
de la chaîne de valeur du médicament
ont alors été lancé plusieurs appels
d'offres que vous nous présenterez
visant à relocaliser la production de
certains médicaments ou principes actifs
grâce au budget colossal du plan de
relance puis de France 2030
mais les gouvernements successifs dont
vous avez fait partie ont aussi
poursuivi la compression à la baisse des
dépenses de santé que certains nous
disent difficilement soutenables pour la
production de médicaments matures alors
que la France a subi de nombreux chocs
externes et connaît désormais une
inflation élevée vous pourrez nous
parler du rôle que joue le prix du
médicament et sa réglementation qui font
la spécificité de l'industrie
pharmaceutique en France nous souhaitons
vous entendre aujourd'hui pour tirer le
bilan de votre action entre 2018 et 2022
en matière de sécurisation de
l'approvisionnement industriel en
médicaments de notre système de santé et
ce sur toute la chaîne de valeur depuis
la chimie jusque au conditionnement nous
savons que les causes des pénuries de
médicament sont multiples allant des
circuits de distribution au choc de
demande il y a du conjoncturel et du
structurel mais au fondement de notre
travail se trouve la question de la
production en France dernier filet de
sécurité pour notre pays en pour notre
pays en cas la pénurie grave de fait les
pénuries s'aggravent d'année en année et
représentent déjà aujourd'hui une
urgence de santé publique je rappellerai
que nous avions avec Madame la
rapporteur fait partie d'une mission du
Sénat à l'été 2018 et les pénuries
étaient estimées entre 700 et 800
médicaments nous sommes actuellement
rendus suivant les semaines entre 2500
et 3000 voir parfois des pics au-dessus
cette capacité à produire est justement
au cœur de votre ancien portefeuille
ministériel il nous semble que l'État
pourrait bien souvent aller plus loin
pour piloter l'approvisionnement aux
médicaments voire dirigé plus
directement une production de
médicaments pour répondre en cas
d'urgence ou de défaut de la production
industrielle
pour cette audition d'une durée environ
d'une heure et demie nous vous laissons
tout d'abord la parole pour un propos
général de 10 minutes puis madame
Laurence Cohen rapporteur de notre
commission d'enquête vous posera des
questions plus précises je précise
également que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête est passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434-13 434 et
434-15 du code pénal je vous invite
madame la ministre après tes serments de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
en levant la main droite et en disant je
le jure
je vous remercie vous avez la parole
madame la ministre
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
Madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs je vous remercie de
m'accueillir au titre de mes anciennes
fonctions de ministre délégués à
l'industrie au sein de votre commission
d'enquête consacrée au sujet de la
pénurie des médicaments et de la
politique de relocalisation des produits
de santé que nous avons engagés sous les
îles sous l'égide du président de la
République
dans ce contexte il est nécessaire de
bien comprendre la situation pour
améliorer la réponse que le gouvernement
y apporte et cette commission y
contribuera certainement pour ma part je
vais tâcher de me concentrer sur la
situation telle que je l'ai connu entre
2018 et 2022
effectivement en tant que secrétaire
d'État puis ministre en charge de
l'Industrie peut-être pour commencer un
peu d'historique avant la crise covid la
France est très bien placée en
production des médicaments en 2007 elle
est première dans l'Union européenne et
on voit qu'elle perd à partir de cette
date mais de manière
générale parallèle à la des industriels
qu'elle a pu connaître progressivement
cette place et aujourd'hui sur 15 ans
plus tard elle serait grosso modo en
5ème position il y avait un débat
quatrième 5e 6e mais en gros elle a
glissé et perdue sa pôle position
c'est l'histoire d'un déclassement avec
la conjonction de plusieurs facteurs que
vous avez je crois déjà entendu lors de
cette commission
un premier point qui n'est pas propre à
la France c'est une période historique
de chute de brevet avec des molécules
devenant moins attractives à produire
plus facile à générique et donc le
développement de production de ces
molécules en dehors de France en dehors
d'Europe d'ailleurs aussi très largement
deuxième élément une hausse des coûts
directs et du poids réglementaire
notamment en matière environnementale
qui va creuser l'écart par rapport au
coût des mêmes productions dans d'autres
géographies lesquelles
prennent des parts de marché
progressivement donc aussi
deviennent
compétentes dans la production des
médicaments donc c'est un double effet
on creuse l'écart mais il y a aussi une
montée en compétences des pays en
question
troisième élément et c'est l'ancienne
directrice de cabinet l'Assistance
publique hôpitaux de Paris qui vous
l'indique puisque j'ai été à cette
position entre 2003 et 2006 un projet de
loi de finances de sécurité sociale qui
conçoit son volet médicament comme une
financement des produits de santé comme
une variable d'ajustement et donc comme
vous l'entendez c'est pas très nouveau
c'est quelque chose que moi j'ai vécu
étant à l'hôpital et sur le financement
des molécules innovantes mais qui est je
dirais une tendance de fond me
semble-t-il de notre régulation
dernière élément c'est le cadre en
matière de régulation qui est
désavantageux en particulier pour les
molécules matures et qui a eu tendance à
se durcir au fil des années donc je me
mets dans une perspective à 15-20 ans
le résultat vous le connaissez donc
c'est ce glissement de place de la
première à la cinquième place au sein de
l'Union européenne donc une perte de
compétitivité vis-à-vis de l'Union
européenne et au plan international 80%
des principes actifs qui sont
aujourd'hui produits en Chine et en Inde
et dernier élément des ruptures
d'approvisionnement en particulier sur
des molécules qui sont pas si compliqué
que ça à produire mais qui sont matures
et qui donc présentent moins d'intérêt
lorsqu'on a un appareil de production
pharmaceutique à produire que d'autres
molécules sur fond de croissance des
besoins en produits de santé il y a
aussi cet effet de vases communicants si
le marché est en croissance parce que un
certain nombre de pays
se développent et répondent mieux aux
besoins de santé de leur population se
déplacent aussi les productions et
lorsque l'innovation elle-même
se déplace et bien on abandonne un peu
progressivement un certain nombre de
produits matures
dès le premier quinquennat et avant la
crise covid une prise de conscience a eu
lieu sur la nécessité de réagir face à
cette dégradation alarmante le premier
comité stratégique des industries de
santé du quinquennat s'est tenu en
juillet 2018 n'était pas encore au
gouvernement mais très clairement en
prenant mes fonctions en octobre 2018
c'est conclusions étaient claires nous
devions les appliquer et elle visait
notamment à apporter une ambition
focalisée fortement sur les produits
innovants
nous avons également lorsque nous avons
travaillé sur le pacte productif qui a
ensuite c'est un nom de travail permis
de nourrir le plan de relance et le plan
France 2030 puisque on avait toute cette
masse de travail accumulée
focaliser nos travaux sur la
bioproduction en particulier sur les
thérapies cellulaires donc un certain
nombre de
nouvelles orientations en matière de
produits de santé sur lequel la France
était pas très bien on pouvait être
mieux positionné
enfin sur les molécules matures c'est le
constat de la ministre de la Santé de
l'époque Agnès Buzyn qui commande en
septembre 2019 une mission à Monsieur
bio pour je cite faire des propositions
d'approvision pour limiter le risque de
rupture d'approvisionnement dans un
objectif de sécurité sanitaire au fin de
renouer avec une stratégie européenne
d'indépendance et de souveraineté dans
le domaine pharmaceutique ce rapport a
d'ailleurs été rendu peut-être qu'un
jour avant de démarrage de la crise
covid si on la positionne du côté de
mi-mars
donc il était de très grande actualité
par rapport à ce que nous avons vécu la
crise du covid a été évidemment un
accélérateur de la prise de conscience
avec je pense deux éléments 1 à la mis
en évidence les chaînes
d'approvisionnement leur complexité le
fait pour un vaccin et Rennes par
exemple il faut 280 composants donc il
ne suffit pas de sécuriser le principe
actif et de sécuriser deux ou trois
étapes de production il faut avoir en
tête tous les flexibles tous les les
capsules les flacons enfin tout ce qui
va rentrer dans la fabrication
de ce type de produit donc ça c'est le
premier élément et ça matérialisé aussi
l'éclatement de ces lignes de production
leur concentration
à tel point que si on doit raisonner
crise il faut aussi raisonner monocytes
c'est à dire que si vous avez une
concentration au-delà de la
concentration par pays mais dans un site
et que ce site a un accident un incendie
ou quelque chose de cette sorte vous
pouvez avoir une un impact non
négligeable sur la production mondiale
et ça cette vulnérabilité qui est je
dirais le fruit d'une sur optimisation
probablement de nos chaînes de
production a été mis en évidence
deuxième élément très factuellement elle
a mis en évidence le fait que lorsqu'il
a s'agit de produire un certain nombre
de produits nous n'avions pas les
capacités de production en France et je
pense de la manière la plus frappante
sur un produit
les enseignes pas les enseignements mais
le
d'exploiter la réglementation européenne
qui permettait de soutenir le
développement de toute production de
produits de santé en lien avec le covid
avec de haut niveau de soutien public
cette a émis a permis de soutenir des
produits innovants matures vaccins
composants dispositifs médicaux
diagnostic in vitro et consommables
un deuxième ami a été relancé d'ailleurs
en février 2021 face à l'ampleur du
projet du besoin pardon et au total
c'est 42 projets qui ont été soutenus
pour un total de soutien public de
l'ordre de 500 millions d'euros et un
total d'investissement de plus de 800
millions d'euros
alors des exemples c'est par exemple des
lignes de production de vaccins
injectables en format unidose
c'est des bouchons techniques ou
standard stériles pour les vaccins
ce sont des lipides qui sont nécessaires
avec 6 nations de la RN donc on voit
cette logique de composants qui font
partie d'une chaîne d'approvisionnement
en parallèle et ça a été un des enjeux
du plan de relance vous savez que dans
le plan de relance on a
repéré cinq secteurs stratégiques plus
un secteur transversal qui sont les
matériaux critiques mais cinq secteurs
stratégiques automobiles aviation etc et
santé et que nous avons soutenu le
renforcement de nos capacités
industrielles dans ces secteurs c'est un
appel à projet qui a visué visé à
diminuer notre dépendance nationale et
européenne et à obtenir un impact
significatif économique et industrielle
le tout dans des délais rapides
les résultats sont les suivants 128
projets pour près de 160 millions
d'euros d'aide donc on n'est pas du tout
sur le même exercice là on est vraiment
sur un exercice de réindustrialisation
et de projection au-delà de du
traitement des covid et donc au total
nous avons soutenu sur cette période
près de 87 projets
qui ont permis de générer 1,8 milliards
d'investissements alors des exemples
complémentaires des projets autour des
principes actifs notamment à ses coins
on a beaucoup parlé du principe un peu
actif du paracétamol mais il y en avait
d'autres dans l'Isère des projets pour
rendre plus vert et plus performants
notre outil de production de principes
actifs chez Minakem dans les
Hauts-de-France
ou des projets sur des principes actifs
anticancéreux dans le cadre du
traitement du mélanome chez Pierre Fabre
à Gaillac voilà trois exemples parmi
d'autres
enfin et cet été tout l'objet du travail
que nous avons fait à la fois de d'aller
jusqu'au bout du des conclusions du
précédent comité stratégique des
industries de santé et de préparer le
futur comité stratégique des industries
de santé
nous avons travaillé à des réponses
structurales
notamment dans la régulation c'est la
conclusion d'un nouvel accord cadre
l'aime c'est ceps avec un chapitre dédié
aux mesures d'attractivité et permettant
de favoriser la relocalisation des
productions et plusieurs dispositions
destinées à maintenir une offre
suffisante de médicaments dans un
objectif de santé publique et nous avons
débouchés dans le cadre du comité
stratégique des industries de santé de
l'été 2021 avec un ensemble de mesures
fortes alors notamment le fait d'avoir
un nom d'âme sur les produits de santé
qui soit à 2,4%
je souris parce que
toujours été à différents endroits de la
construction de l'ondables je sais
comment on peut le construire dans un
sens et le déconstruire de l'autre
la question effectivement d'avoir un
le décret accès direct à un accès direct
pour les produits de santé au marché ce
qu'on appelle en mauvais français le got
Market qui était un des éléments mis en
avant comme étant très
nuisible à la compétitivité à
l'attractivité de la France comparée à
d'autres pays je pense notamment à
l'Allemagne de mémoire c'est ça je dis
pas de bêtises comme j'ai voilà
et dont on voit aujourd'hui les fruits
puisque sur ces différents sujets
l'utilisation de France 2030 avec un
accenté très fort de 7,5 milliards
d'euros de crédit fléchés le décret
accès direct ou la mise en œuvre du
niveau à corps ceps je comprends que
c'est maintenant en 2023 que nous
commençons à en voir la mise en œuvre
pratique
dernier point c'est une action niveau
européen puisque en tant que ministre en
charge de l'Industrie et présidente du
Conseil Compétitivité j'ai pas reporté
forcément fortement un axe santé et
notamment un pied santé
qui visait accompagner
un certain nombre de domaines je pense
encore une fois à la question des
principes actifs deuxième question celle
des biothérapies des bio-productions sur
lequel nous avions une position fragile
et de manière générale celle d'avoir un
appareil de production ARN jusqu'au de
la du traitement du covid les
perspectives offertes par la mise en
oeuvre de
thérapie de type ARN semblait importante
encore une fois moi je ne suis pas
médecin mais c'est ce qui semblait
ressortir de l'écoute des experts et le
fait que nous avions assez peu de
structures de production qui permettait
de le faire donc ce sont des sujets sur
lequel nous avions ouvert assez
fortement
la porte avec une discussion dont je
comprends qu'elle continue à se
dérouler mais où nous avons pu déposer
des projets ce qui est une très bonne
nouvelle et j'espère que la Commission
européenne nous reviendra fin 2023 mais
vous voyez entre le moment on a commencé
à en parler et peut-être la première
décision on parle de trois ans ce qui
dans ces matières technologies rapide
témoignent de la quantité d'énergie
qu'il faut mettre pour faire avancer les
sujets
alors ces actions
elles sont
évidemment insuffisantes si on mesure
l'augmentation en tout cas la situation
de pénurie sur un certain nombre de
molécules il y a plusieurs raisons je
pense autour de ça la première raison
structurelle c'est qu'on a longtemps
guidé notre politique de soutien aux
produits de santé ou en tout cas
d'accompagnement des produits de santé
en se focalisant sur les innovations
et il faut avoir en tête que c'est pas
le même modèle innovation et produit
mature mais que 1 dans un portefeuille
de de d'entreprises
les produits matures permettent de
financer l'innovation et donc de mettre
et de faire toutes les réductions de
tarifs sur les produits nature conduit
une Phinée à reposer la question du
financement de l'innovation à côté et
deuxièmement en termes
d'industrialisation en fait ce phénomène
de
molécules matures chassées par les
molécules innovantes qui fait que peu à
peu on diminue l'appareil de production
mondiale de ces molécules matures et
donc on crée des effets de de pénurie
qui ensuite sont gérés par le prix donc
le prix est un des éléments explicatifs
c'est pas le seul mais ce qui est en
tout état de cause il va ensuite gérer
la file d'attente
et donc sur les deux sujets qui à la
fois pensé et comment on accompagne les
molécules matures et on s'assure
qu'elles soient produites et on n'a pas
nécessairement
la nécessité de produire sur le sol
français dès lors qu'on a sécurisé des
approvisionnements et qui dit sécuriser
des approvisionnements dit avoir au
moins deux sources d'approvisionnement
et de préférence des sources qui soient
pas trop lointaines et donc mise en jeu
par des problèmes de chaîne logistique
si on est très concret deuxième élément
c'est une forme
difficulté à avoir une cohérence totale
entre les différentes actions publiques
je pense notamment à la commande
publique
on a avec Olivier Véran bataillé pendant
6 mois pour écrire une circulaire qui
permettait aux hôpitaux et qui
recommandaient aux autres établissements
utilisant des équipements de protection
individuelle de privilégier en tout cas
de retenir dans l'achat publique de
prendre en compte les risques du rupture
et le fait que peut-être payer un peu
plus cher vous pouvez aussi sécuriser
des productions et garantir contre des
risques de rupture d'approvisionnement
de constater que ces circulaires ont pas
franchement été mises en oeuvre et que
il y a un risque d'injonction paradoxale
à la fois sur l'optimisation de la
structure de coûts des établissements de
santé d'un côté et de l'autre côté le
fait que dans l'achat publique vous
pouvez privilégier un prix un peu plus
élevé en contre pour comment dire
obtenir en contrepartie
une sécurisation de votre
approvisionnement on peut d'ailleurs
réfléchir à des systèmes d'allotissement
qui permettent d'avoir une plusieurs
fournisseurs et donc il sécurise les
fournisseurs qui a garantissent contre
la rupture d'approvisionnement versus
des fournisseurs qui ont des prix très
très compétitifs et qui permettent
d'avoir des soins aux meilleurs prix
mais c'est logique là il gagnerait à
être développé enfin l'articulation avec
avec Bruxelles je pense que il y a une
vraie avancée avec la création de la RA
avec l'idée de la doté de compétences en
matière notamment en temps de crise et
d'anticipation de crise possible le pied
qui est lancé mais effectivement il faut
s'assurer que ces politiques se
poursuivent et débouches et si on
regarde une comparaison avec la barda on
est encore loin de l'ambition en termes
de mais également d'équipe de staffing
et de moyens financiers
de la Barda et puis dernier point la
politique de prix je n'y reviens pas je
sais que vous avez entendu le président
du CEPS je pense que c'est un point sur
lequel il faut utiliser tous les textes
qui ont enfin l'intégralité de l'accord
l'intégralité le décret accès direct
tout ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui était mis
en place et avec beaucoup de de
détermination lors de la mandature
précédente pour que ça porte ses fruits
et effectivement il est très tôt bien
trop tôt pour porter un jugement sur
l'effectivité de ces mesures et je sais
que des résultats sont attendus bientôt
aussi dans le cadre de la mission
régulation
lancée par la première ministre
voilà je
pense que j'ai tout dit évidemment
les outils comme innovation France 2030
et
le renforcement de notre souveraineté
industrielle dans le domaine
pharmaceutique avec les politiques qui
ont été menées me semble avoir montré
leur efficacité et la question c'est de
savoir comment on les prend prolonge et
quelle forme elles prennent en temps de
j'allais dire en temps de paix mais
c'est pas le long terme mais dans un
contexte qui est normalisé en termes de
pendule
en tout cas je sais que c'est ce à quoi
s'emploie prenons Lescure et François
Brune qui nous ont succédé
très bien merci beaucoup madame la mini
je passe tout de suite la parole à
Laurence Cohen rapporteur pour une
première série de questions
oui merci madame la ministre pour vos
explications et vos précisions alors par
rapport à aux éléments que vous nous
avez donné effectivement cette politique
de délocalisation en fait de l'industrie
pharmaceutique ne date pas
de d'un seul mandat présidentiel ou un
sans faut puisque comme ça a été
souligné ça fait une vingtaine voire une
trentaine d'années qui a cette politique
de délocalisation
avec en fait ce qu'il faut bien avouer
c'est à dire un calcul de
rentabilité optimale on va dire qui ont
fait que les entreprises ont préféré
aller s'installer dans des pays à
moindre coût ou moins d'exigences on va
dire de critères sociaux et
environnementaux plutôt que de rester en
France et aussi on a quand même quelque
chose à apprendre en compte dans la dans
la
conception qu'on a d'une manière
générale la société si tout le monde dit
aujourd'hui oui il faudrait relocaliser
l'industrie chimique l'industrie
chimique est polluante et
les gens ont tendance à dire y compris
au plus haut niveau d'accord mais pas
ici pas chez nous pas sur nos
territoires il y a aussi tout tous ces
blocages là à prendre en compte
aujourd'hui il y a donc une volonté de
relocaliser nous avons eu différentes
auditions qui l'ont qui l'ont montré
cette relocalisation
elle se fait
avec des aides publiques notamment et le
gouvernement
accompagnent ces relocalisations vous en
avez donné des exemples ma question
première question c'est concernant les
garanties qu'on peut avoir sur ces
relocalisations c'est à dire en fait
des entreprises qui ont délocalisé qui
ont été aidés aujourd'hui ont un nouveau
des aides public pour relocaliser mais
quel est le notre garantie pour au moins
affirmer qu'elles vont rester un temps
assez long sur le territoire français et
que d'ici un ou deux ans elles vont pas
repartir sur un autre territoire on a
besoin effectivement d'avoir un certain
nombre de conditions garanties donc ça
c'est ma ma première ma première
question et en fait
je voudrais
y compris vous interroger sur le fait
que pendant votre votre ministère vous
avez donc eu des politiques qui ont fait
que il y a eu certainement des capacités
qui ont été mises en œuvre sur notre
territoire et donc ça serait intéressant
d'avoir un
des éléments sur cette chaîne de
production qui a pu être mise en oeuvre
sur le territoire mais en même temps à
la fois il y a eu cette relocalisation
on va dire ou supprimer de
relocalisation pour être et puis aussi
il y a eu des départs qui ont qui se
sont poursuivis est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir un état précis entre ce qui a pu
se relocaliser en France et ce qui
malheureusement a continué à quitter
notre territoire ça c'est ma première
question ma deuxième question c'est
concernant les les problématiques de
d'attractivité du territoire du
territoire français c'est-à-dire que par
exemple on a vu dans nos différentes
auditions et on l'a vu encore ce matin
avec la présidente en allant à Bercy que
le SIR et une source d'attractivité pour
pour les entreprises pharmaceutiques
c'est un effort considérable qui est
produit par la France pour aider aider
les industries les grands laboratoires
mais là encore il y a des politiques
d'évitement ou d'optimisation on va dire
donc est-ce que aujourd'hui il ne serait
pas
de mettre en place à côté donc du cire
des conditionnalités et notamment nous
avons vu je crois que c'était hier dans
l'édition que nous avons eu avec la
fille aux Cruz au Brésil alors toute
comparaison
gardée parce que on n'est pas dans le
même pays on n'est pas dans la même
histoire etc etc mais il y a des ils ont
la capacité
eux de décider de prendre une décision
sur la production d'un médicament et une
fois que c'est pris une fois que la
recherche a aboutit et bien ils sont en
capacité de produire la barda c'est tout
autre chose encore un autre pays mais
ils ont ces deux conditionnalités c'est
à partir du moment où la recherche
aboutit ils ont la capacité de produire
donc est-ce que nous avec notre histoire
notre réseau industriel on n'aurait pas
aussi cette possibilité au moins de
mettre des conditions pour être sûr que
à partir du moment où il y a une
recherche qui est faite sur le
territoire français la production se
fasse c'est pas sur le territoire
français à la émission le territoire
européen mais en tout cas que les
médicaments produits soient destinés en
priorité à la France est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui vous semble
réalisable possible et sous quelles
conditions toujours un peu dans le même
ordre d'idée maintenant vous êtes au
niveau de la transition
écologique on a vu que il y a besoin
effectivement aujourd'hui de mettre en
place des des critères des critères au
niveau de du respect des normes sociales
mais aussi des normes environnementales
mais les industriels que nous avons
auditionnées nous disent que à partir du
moment où ils vont respecter ces normes
quelque part il faut en tenir compte
parce que sinon d'autres pays qui ne
respecteraient pas ces normes serait
d'une manière injuste dans la même
course que mais avec pas de handicap
alors que aurait un handicap qu'est-ce
que vous vous envisagez par rapport à
cet état de fait et est-ce qu'il est
d'une manière envisagée entre votre
ministère celui de la santé les
différents ministères intéressés
finalement de mettre en quelque sorte
une clause enfin pas une clause mais un
label plutôt sur les médicaments
concernant cette ce respect
environnemental une espèce un espèce de
label peut-être souveraineté je sais pas
on l'appelle comme comme on le souhaite
ça c'était ma troisième question
ma quatrième question c'est concernant
la clause de sauvegarde
la clause de sauvegarde elle a d'abord
été mise en place
essentiellement par rapport aux
médicaments innovants puis elle
s'élargit aux médicaments matures dans
les auditions que nous avons entendues
il nous a été dit que c'était un
handicap pour les laboratoires en ce
sens où il n'avait pas de vision
d'anticipation c'est à dire au moment où
effectivement il devait s'acquitter de
cette clause de sauvegarde il le savait
qu'en bout de course mais pas au départ
donc est-ce que là aussi parce que il me
semblerait pas judicieux de la supprimer
parce que c'est un apport conséquent au
caisse de la sécurité sociale mais
est-ce qu'il est envisagé une modulation
qu'est-ce qui peut être envisagée ou pas
au niveau de cette clause de de
sauvegarde d'autant que je fais la
corrélation avec le fait que
l'État français le gouvernement est
quand même
de moyens face aux industriels et ma
question c'est est-ce que l'État
finalement fait le poids quand il s'agit
d'imposer des prix on a vu quand même
des bras de fer assez assez importantes
au niveau des des négociations au vu des
prix critiqués si je prends qu'un
exemple celui des vaccins contre le
covid 19 bien par exemple la direction
de Sanofi avait dit qu'ils iraient en
priorité au plus offrant c'est-à-dire
les États-Unis donc face à ce genre
d'attitude ou face au négociations qui
sont difficiles on l'a vu avec le CEPS
quels sont les moyens de l'État pour
obliger à raison garder et qu'il n'y ait
pas effectivement des prix d'un côté qui
s'envolent je pense notamment aux
médicaments aux médicaments innovants
enfin ma dernière question concerne
l'Europe vous l'avez dit vous l'avez
souligné vous avez contribué à lancer le
pied santé et je pense on peut dire que
la France y a joué un rôle un rôle
moteur donc c'est quelque chose de
positif on a vu au courant au cours de
nos auditions que il est absolument
impossible de penser politique du
médicament
franco-française c'est une réflexion qui
doit se faire au niveau au niveau
européen voire mondial mais en tout cas
le rôle de l'Europe est extrêmement
extrêmement important mais après
quelques années il semblerait que quand
même les ambitions qui étaient affichées
qui étaient juste ont été un peu
réduites à une part congrue donc est-ce
que vous êtes confiant finalement dans
cette approche et qu'est-ce qui peut
être amélioré pour faire en sorte que
finalement les ambitions affichées et
bien s'avère positive et respecté plutôt
que d'être finalement revu à la baisse
je vous remercie
pour compléter sur la clause de
sauvegarde on a eu un exemple il y a peu
de témoignages d'une entreprise de 135
salariés donc
qui a vu sa cause de sauvegarde avec de
40 000 euros il y a 4 ans qui est
désormais à 160.000 euros sans avoir pu
l'anticiper et avec une CAF de
l'entreprise qui a baissé de 3 % donc on
voit bien que à un moment ce sujet là
est un vrai sujet percutant
merci beaucoup je vais essayer de vous
répondre
certaines questions sont plus
prospectives elles relèvent moins je
dirais de mon positionnement actuel donc
je me permettrai de renvoyer le caixe
sur mes collègues sur les
délocalisations
je dirais que le premier élément qui
envoie enfin conduit
d'abord de nouveaux acteurs parce qu'il
faut avoir en tête aussi qu'il y a des
nouveaux acteurs qui qui ont qui sont
apparus sur le marché mondial
c'est-à-dire tout n'est pas une
délocalisation ça peut être tout
simplement une concurrence entre le
porteur du brevet initial qui dont le
brevet tombe et qui est confronté à
l'apparition de nouveaux acteurs
produisant le principe génériques dans
des pays dans leur pays d'origine en
l'occurrence puisque s'agissant de
l'Inde et de la Chine c'est pas
nécessairement des les Big Pharma qui
sont localisés mais ce sont souvent des
entreprise très importante mais
d'origine du pays et qui savent
construire plus rapidement que nous des
usines dans des conditions où alors il y
a deux niveaux de normes il y a l'énorme
environnementales général et vous avez
raison de souligner que beaucoup de
sites sont CV2 et qu'en règle générale
ça suscite pas un antiosiasme débordant
lorsqu'on annonce la construction
d'acide seuils Seveso et deuxièmement
les normes propres à la pharmacie c'est
à dire qu'en plus nous avons nous des
exigences en matière de qualité de
traçabilité de la production qui ont
évidemment sont des garanties pour les
patients mais qui inversement conduisent
à des coûts supplémentaires pour pouvoir
les tenir et c'est la somme de ses coûts
supplémentaires plus le fait que vous
êtes sur des pays dont la base de coûts
et assez naturellement inférieur à celle
de l'Europe qui a conduit avoir émergé
de nouveaux acteurs très
en termes de quantité de production qui
ont d'ailleurs été absolument
indispensables lorsqu'il a fallu mettre
en place des chaînes de production
mondiale de l'axe ils ont très largement
contribué à fournir une partie des
éléments de ces de ces vaccins mais
néanmoins c'est un constat donc c'est
pas nécessairement des délocalisations
ça peut être tout simplement une
répartition des parts de marché avec des
acteurs qui ont des coûts de structure
plus importants qui ont l'habitude de
produire dans des pays au coup de
structure plus élevés et qui du coup se
positionne là où ils ont plus de chance
de faire la différence les sur les
produits innovants puisque ils ont des
capacités de recherche et de
développement plus importantes et ils
ferment ce qui marche pas et qui perdent
de l'argent moi je le définirais plutôt
comme ça en termes de
délocalisation
ensuite par rapport aux news que ce que
nous proposons de faire ce que nous
avons fait pour
sécuriser de nouveaux sites la
construction
[Musique]
fait partie des équipes et de toute
façon sur des niveaux de rémunération
qui tendent à converger dans le temps
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui un cadre en
Chine est mieux payé qu'en France dès
lors qu'en plus ils parlent anglais sur
un certain nombre et je parle de cadre
de directeur industriels de genre de
responsable de méthode etc pas du patron
de l'entreprise mais des gens en dessous
donc la différence me semble-t-il se
joue plus sur les normes plus sur
l'enjeu des brevets plus on enjeu
l'enjeu aussi du marché domestique
et ça c'est peut-être aussi une réponse
à l'Europe nous avons un marché
domestique avec ces normes ces
régulations propres pour 67 millions de
consommateurs potentiels
la Chine c'est peut-être pas un milliard
deux mais disons 450 millions de
personnes qui sont situées sur la partie
de la côte
orientale et qui correspond en gros à
l'équivalent d'une classe moyenne
en termes de consommation les États-Unis
c'est 350 millions de personnes
et donc en termes d'attractivité des
marchés vous avez une différence entre
un petit marché et un grand marché et ça
devrait inspirer je pense l'Europe ne
serait-ce que pour avoir des
convergences de règles pour éviter
d'avoir des régulations qui soient
parfois un peu contradictoires pour
devoir refaire des dossiers
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
même si vous avez une agence unique tous
ces éléments sont probablement des
éléments qui ne sont pas budgétaires
mais qui peuvent aider à
renforcer l'accès au marché
l'attractivité du marché européen
sur
et donc
sans la conditionnalité et créée par
elle-même c'est-à-dire le coût qui
accepte de signer sur un endroit où
c'est plus coûteux de produire un
laboratoire pharmaceutique
est en soi une conditionnalité de rester
au fond ce que nous
tamponnons c'est l'écart de coût par
rapport à un site construire ailleurs
pas tellement plus ou tellement moi
et l'accès à notre marché qui doit être
facilité et ça c'est la c'est la
question de la régulation en face
sur la question du cirque
moi j'attire l'attention sur une chose
c'est que le crédit impôt recherche
aujourd'hui est un outil qui permet de
ramener le coup du chercheur français ou
même coup que celui du chercheur
allemand parce que je rappelle que notre
système de cotisation sociale fait que
alors je sais des vieux souvenirs de
Bercy mais grosso modo là de 80 000
euros de coûts par an le la personne
rémunérée en Allemagne paye moins de
cotisations sociales puisque vous avez
un jeu de qui est des plafonné qui est
pas déplafonnés etc et donc toute la
baisse de nos cotisations sociales comme
vous le savez elle s'arrête à 2,5 fois
le SMIC et ensuite on a un niveau de
cotisation sociale qui est en termes de
la raison européenne bien supérieure à
ceux de nos homologues et avec un
certain nombre de d'endroits où elles
sont des plafonnées donc ça clairement
le cire permet de rattraper ça donc
c'est une correction je dirais pas que
c'est désormais un élément
d'attractivité en soi je pense qu'en
revanche retirer le cirque est un
élément de perte de compétitivité
claire puisque ça mettrait le coup des
centres de recherche à des niveaux bien
plus élevés bien plus élevé plus élevé
que des homologues de même
type que nous en termes de PIB par tête
ou de développement type Allemagne enfin
voilà type de voisins proches
et donc je recommande d'être
précautionneux sur l'utilisation du cire
en revanche effectivement tous les
systèmes comme temps ont pu être pointé
du doigt de contournement de mode de
calcul ça c'est
comme la fiscalité il y a ceux qui
l'utilisent normalement et à ceux qui
l'optimisent dans un sens qui n'est pas
conforme à la lettre l'esprit de la loi
et donc qui conforme à la lettre n'est
pas l'esprit de la loi et ça c'est une
autre c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
réparer
et puis nous avions sur la partie
capacity building prévue effectivement
des retours en termes de
réservation de production mais qui était
propre à ce système là puisque c'était
moins de réindustrialisation qui était
poursuivie que la volonté de sécuriser
des approvisionnements
sur les critères de respect des normes
sociales et environnementales
en tout cas dans tout ce qui est marché
public il y a toujours la notion d'avoir
un critère objectif sur lequel puisse
s'appuyer les acheteurs publics et à ce
titre tout critère objectif sur lesquels
peut s'appuyer sans discussion possible
vis-à-vis du juge etc n'acheteur public
et bon à prendre avec
donc un label qui permet de dire dans
les marchés publics vous avez la belle
et donc ça vous rapporte des points en
plus par exemple
avec un point de vigilance qui est de
s'assurer que les PME et les moyens de
se faire labelliser par rapport à des
grands groupes
et je sais que
dans le cadre du projet industriel verte
et de toutes les réflexions qui ont été
liées à ça il y a un travail sur un
label d'excellence environnementale qui
puisse plus largement au-delà de la
santé servir comme référentiel pour pour
l'achat
sur la question de la clause de
sauvegarde
on peut dire très basiquement que
ce qui est troublant c'est que c'est une
clause qui a été mise en oeuvre pour
agir de temps en temps qu'il réagit
systématiquement et pour des montants de
plus en plus importants donc là aussi on
peut penser que l'Esprit dans lesquels a
été créé elle a été créée ne correspond
plus à son mode de fonctionnement actuel
il me semble que c'est un des enjeux de
la mission régulation que de tracer des
pistes pour regarder son fonctionnement
ce qui est également certain et ça
c'était une des difficultés liées à
London c'est mais qui n'est pas propre
d'ailleurs que seul sujet des produits
de santé c'est qu'avoir sa norme de
dépenses au milieu de l'année ou en fin
d'année c'est compliqué pour la gestion
mais c'est valable pour les hôpitaux
aussi
sur
alors ensuite est-ce que l'État fait le
poids dans la négociation oui parce
qu'elle obtient en fait le marché
français même si on n'a pas une grande
transparence on n'a pas des benchmark
établi mais le marché français est
présumé ayant le prix du médicament un
des prix des médicaments les plus
compétitifs c'est assez facile à établir
par comparaison avec les États-Unis
c'était plus difficile à établir par
comparaison avec d'autres pays européens
mais c'est assez largement partagé par
par les experts ce qui témoignent quand
même de la capacité de l'État français
dans ces différentes composantes à
négocier et à négocier plutôt de manière
très dure les prix du médicament
est-ce qu'il y a un versement
les
et donc non voilà je m'arrête là je
pense que le sujet que nous avons nous
c'est ensuite est-ce qu'on articule ce
qu'a fait la barda sur la production de
vaccins je finance toute la recherche et
du coup vous devez vous me devez une
production
dans le pays
ça c'est une question qui peut se poser
mais alors
financé toute la recherche et donc
prendre en charge un montant assez
conséquent de financement et ton prêt à
faire cela évidemment il y a la question
de l'incitation à chercher à chercher
bien si une partie a trop importante et
prise en charge et puis il y a la
question derrière de choisir nos combats
c'est à dire pour quel type de classe
thérapeutique je sais qu'il y a une
mission qui a été que moi j'avais initié
puisque au début on avait dans le cadre
du Plan résilience lancer des des appels
à projets qui concernaient notamment les
molécules d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeur mais vu la longueur de la liste
c'était assez large
et j'avais lancé une mission qui a
atterri après mon départ qui associer
différents corps de contrôle notamment
pour resserrer et aller préciser les
peut-être
200 300 molécules qui méritaient
vraiment qu'on investisse pour pour des
raisons de santé publique et évidemment
c'était les gars le CGE qui qui avait
piloté cette mission mission gorgée
voilà et donc sur l'Europe une première
réflexion ce qui a été fait au niveau de
la santé sur l'Europe et quand même
extraordinairement audacieux s'agissant
d'une compétence qui est qui relève des
pays des États membres donc ils sont
allés bien au-delà de ce que prévoyait
les traiter etc et plutôt de manière
efficace il faut le reconnaître deuxième
élément
c'est ce que je vous indiquais je pense
qu'il y a un travail à faire sur
l'innovation et et les pieds sont une
bonne un bon moyen de le faire et de pas
s'arrêter à l'innovation mais d'aller
jusqu'à l'industrialisation ça sert
souvent aussi été un de nos peut-être
une de nos limites de beaucoup soutenir
l'innovation mais pas l'innovation
complet à l'industrialisation et la
deuxième chose c'est de regarder tout ce
qui peut être obstacle à la diffusion
d'un médicament
sur l'ensemble de l'Europe c'est à dire
ce qui est en particulier pour des
petites entreprises ou même des startups
lorsque vous devez faire
reconnaître pour une mise sur le marché
dans 27 pays c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose que le faire reconnaître dans
un seul pays comme c'est le cas aux
États-Unis et donc tout ce qui peut
aider à avoir des reconnaissances
réciproques des
des temps raccourcis des pratiques qui
somogénisent qui se rapprochent et qui
évite
aux industriels de devoir connaître par
cœur 27 réglementations sur le bout des
doigts qui ont toutes des petits
éléments de différenciation qui
représentent des coûts un peu différents
des manières de produire un peu
différente des manières de documenter
les bonnes pratiques pharmaceutiques
dans leur site de manière différente
peut aider et ça ça ne coûte pas cher
et ça permet d'avoir accès à un marché
450 millions de personnes éduquées avec
un pouvoir d'achat important et ça
devient un marché très intéressant
puisque vous avez cette double dimension
combien on paye le médicament mais aussi
à quel marché j'ai accès
voilà et peut-être pour financer tout ça
j'ai relu avec intérêt
la
l'audition de mon collègue Olivier
Varent je pense que la question de la
régulation enfin de la prescription et
de se dire que si on sait gérer le sujet
de la quantité prescrite en France qui
est plutôt plus importante que dans
d'autres pays avec des risques de
iatrogénie non négligeable on pourrait
récupérer des marges de manœuvre pour
bien prescrire les bonnes molécules
qu'on fabrique sur notre territoire
alors c'est peut-être un vœu pieux mais
en tout cas je pense que ça irait dans
la bonne direction
merci beaucoup j'ai passé la parole
à nos collègues Pascal Gruny
merci il y a l'agence de médicaments en
Europe qui travaille et qui avance quand
même aussi sur les sujets d'autorisation
de mise sur le marché en fait au niveau
européen qui pourrait répondre à ce dont
de parler moi j'aurais voulu vous
interroger sur les stocks est-ce qu'il
faut une politique de stock qui porte
les stocks et bien entendu parce que
certaines entreprises m'ont déjà répondu
que comme il y avait déjà des pénuries
et on pouvait pas stocker en fait quand
on est en pénurie mais
on espère qu'un jour on sera plus en
pénurie et donc est-ce qu'il faut mettre
en place une politique de stock et par
qui elle doit être portée c'est-à-dire
est-ce que c'est l'entreprise qui porte
le stock financièrement je parle ou
est-ce que c'est l'état en fait qui qui
doit aider aussi à supporter ce coup
supplémentaire
si vous pouvez répondre
alors sur sur ce sujet là où vous savez
qu'on a revu le décret stock en 2021
avec un minimum de deux mois pour être
reporté à 4 mois sur certains types de
préparation il y a différents sujets qui
sont à prendre en compte il y a d'abord
la durée
de
voilà
qui effectivement pose un certain nombre
de difficultés par rapport à l'idée un
peu théorique on se dit si on fait des
stocks on devrait ne pas avoir de
problème de pénurie il y a un deuxième
sujet qui est cool les coûts sont ainsi
considérables puisque ça c'est du besoin
en fond de roulement donc après qu'il
porte là je dirais c'est une décision de
nature plus politique c'est clairement
pas une décision technique c'est où on
met l'effort et
quel est l'impact que ça en termes
d'attractivité du pays en tout cas ce
que je peux
ce dont je peux témoigner c'est que dans
les échanges que j'ai eu à l'époque avec
les industriels la question du coût des
stocks de l'espace pris par les stocks
de la sécurisation des bonnes conditions
d'entreposage pour que les stocks
restent à tout moment utilisables sans
perdre leur propriété était une question
qui était vécue comme
assez lourde assez contraignante et
plutôt repoussoir par les industriels en
question
je comprends que la question de cette
question elle fait partie des travaux
sur lequel le ministère de la Santé et
François Brown sont en train de préparer
des propositions donc
je n'irai pas plus loin dans mon dans
mon propos
j'ai pas répondu à une question c'est le
bilan fermeture ouverture alors sur le
sol secteur de la santé je ne saurais
pas vous le dire mais de manière globale
sur l'industrie on a un bilan net
positif depuis plusieurs années puisque
on est je crois plus de 90 000 créations
d'emplois nette dans l'industrie
là où on a fait grosso modo moi un
million d'emplois entre
2000 et 2016
alors ça paraît peu c'est énorme puisque
ce sont des secteurs ou vous avez une
concentration enfin un nombre de
personnes pour faire les journées les
usines qui ont eu tendance à structurer
est-ce qu'il serait intéressant de
l'avoir par type de secteur
vous renverrai assez directement vers
mon collègue de l'industrie qui doit
avoir les données de qui peuvent
construire les données plus facilement
que moi depuis l'énergie dans nos
interlocuteurs dès qu'on commence par
demander par type de secteur on se
trouve confronté un gros point
d'interrogation à chaque fois donc on va
essayer de d'aller plus en avant sur
cette question et en plus je pense qu'il
faut faire la différence entre les
différents niveaux de fonction parce que
dans le secteur de la santé c'est
beaucoup le toute la partie
commercialisation qui a fait l'objet de
restructuration c'est ces dernières
années et pas forcément la partie
industrielle mais ça dépend notamment la
partie chimique qui est qui est le
maillon faible
xxl de la chaîne de valeur du médicament
emiliane
oui merci madame la Présidente moi je
voudrais revenir un petit peu sur les
sur les moyennes de l'État les moyens
qu'à l'état pour agir je dirais on ne
peut pas imaginer qu'on puisse avoir une
structure type de celles qu'on a vu hier
au Brésil parce que les conditions sont
complètement différentes mais qu'elle
est quels sont les moyens de la
puissance publique pour réguler un petit
peu ce marché du médicament et donc
éviter les pénuries que l'on voit
aujourd'hui alors vous avez bien remis
en perspective l'histoire du prix des
médicaments matures qu'on a rongé je
crois que c'est Xavier Bertrand qui a
dit jusqu'à l'os donc tout le monde est
d'accord sur ce sur ce constat et sur le
problème la cause sauvegarde vous avez
bien parlé aussi sur la commande
publique finalement l'injonction
contradictoires qui fait aux hôpitaux
qui font des commandes publiques pour
avoir les prix les plus bas et qui peut
pas inclure une clause je dirais de
priorité parce qu'ils sont aussi tenus
par ce fameux homme qui qui n'est pas
fait en fonction des besoins
réels du pays mais en fonction des
dépenses qu'on a fait l'emmener d'avant
ce qui est quand même tout à fait
anormal alors moi vous n'avez pas trop
parler de la transparence des des prix
et on sait bien on lui réponde tout le
temps le secret des affaires c'est
négocié avec le CEPS etc etc mais on
voit bien aujourd'hui que les Big Pharma
qui sont qui datent de 90 c'est les
années 90 où on a vu ces grosses
massification de de l'industrie
pharmaceutique ont quasiment abandonné
j'allais dire la chimie on avait eu le
directeur Sanofi qui nous avait dit mais
la chimie ça nous intéresse plus qui
nous intéresse c'est des rapides et pour
cause entre une boîte de doliprane à
2,14 et un gestes à 3 millions de la
dose le choix est vite fait et donc
on arrive à des demandes de prix qui
sont vraiment exorbitants sur les
produits innovants que peut faire l'état
pour bloquer ces demandes qui sont
vraiment
anormalement élevés
et qui sont faites par des industriels
qui ont fait ce choix de
regarder que l'innovation génique
moi je vais je vais rajouter
une question dans toutes nos auditions
on a vu que et donc c'est votre vraiment
votre point de vue à vous dont vous
fonction à l'époque qui nous intéressent
il a été reproché dans cette comment
dire
dans ce grand écosystème de la santé en
France et donc plus singulièrement du
médicament la multiplicité des acteurs
un fonctionnement un peu en silo un peu
beaucoup on en a eu encore une
confirmation lors de notre visite ce
matin à Bercy entre les objectifs
industriels d'un côté économique et puis
les objectifs de santé mais de santé
publique et les objectifs budgétaires
qu'on retrouve au niveau de la santé
mais si on laissait la santé publique
s'exprimer pleinement les objectifs
budgétaires seraient pas tout à fait les
mêmes il y a fort à parier et on pose
covid on peut considérer que on en a
pris de façon particulièrement rude
conscience et donc il nous a été
plusieurs fois évoqué la question du
pilotage et sur la question des pénuries
de médicaments mais c'est exactement la
même chose pour les dispositifs médicaux
la question du pilotage est importante
et est-ce que vous avez ressenti cette
cette question et en tout cas
manifestement elle reste très prenante
dans les esprits de la part de tous les
acteurs je le précise
et donc est-ce que vous avez à l'époque
déjà envisager une réflexion autour de
ce sujet puisqu'on voit bien là que sur
la question de la pénurie on est en
train de remettre des des structures des
organisations des tasses forces comme on
a fait pendant la covid d'ailleurs on a
remis sur les structures dans d'autres
structures et la maladie française étant
celle de la commitologie voilà il y a un
vrai sujet
et notamment le sujet du pilotage
sanitaire finalement de ces questions là
et quand propose la question de la
réindustrialisation on nous répond
beaucoup emplois politique industrielle
et à chaque fois c'est compliqué d'avoir
une réponse sur l'objectif sanitaire qui
est en tout cas en matière de pénurie
l'objectif quand même principal
et notamment
sa justifie le fait que les
conditionnalités sur la production
sont difficiles à mettre en place et
notamment en matière de production et
d'outils industriels on s'est déplacé à
séquence et euro happy en réalité il y a
aucune condition de mise sur le fait que
la production soit destinée au moins
pour partie non négligeable à la France
alors que l'accompagnement de
financement public est un accompagnement
conséquent et français et la même
question se pose pour le crédit pour
recherche puisque on voit bien que
finalement les brevets ne restent pas
en France ou du moins
l'état de la recherche par avec les
chercheurs avant que le brevet soit
déposé et que c'est dans d'autres pays
plus accueillants et plus propice au
développement industriel que ça se que
ça se passe donc est-ce que c'est un
question de pilotage parce qu'en matière
de pénurie on voit bien que c'est quand
même important à un moment que tout ça
se mette ensemble et que on soit bien
d'accord sur le fait que l'objectif
sanitaire est prépondérant sur les
autres en matière de pénurie de
médicaments
ok
alors sur la question des prix des
molécules innovantes et de la nature de
la négociation moi j'aimerais d'abord
rappeler quelques petites choses le
gendarme budgétaire de la santé c'est la
Direction de la Sécurité sociale
très basiquement dans le jeu dans
l'écosystème et le jeu d'acteur ce son
travail c'est reconnu
Bercy dans nous ce que nous avions porté
nous n'étions pas à verse à
l'augmentation de la dépense dans un
rôle qui n'était pas celui de la
Direction du Budget évidemment mais mais
je
le redis avec une logique justement de
entre guillemets retomber de retour sur
investissement c'est à dire la
préconisation que nous avions c'était
d'anticiper quels étaient les retombées
attendues d'un certain nombre de
décisions est-ce que c'est retombé en
termes d'emploi évidemment en termes de
création aussi d'emploi indignés induit
puisque un emploi industriel c'est 3-4
emplois induits sur le territoire
français mais c'était aussi en termes de
sécurisation d'approvisionnement et
lorsque
on a cette sécurité on peut aussi éviter
la des effets de volatilité et des
effets de tout le coup de la rupture et
pénurie donc c'était tout cela que nous
essayons de visualiser et en ayant une
vision de la sécurisation des chaînes de
valeurs qui n'étaient pas nécessairement
que produire en France moi je m'en
rappelle avoir donné un coup de main à
ma collègue autrichienne pour maintenir
une production
d'antibiotiques ou en tout cas pour
aborder un dossier de production
d'antibiotiques justement pour sécuriser
un des derniers sites européens de
production d'antibiotiques en disant bah
si nous on sait pas vous aider enfin à
un moment on va avoir un vrai problème
collectif donc
la sécurisation des chaînes de valeur
c'est savoir où ces produits et à
quelles conditions ça peut disparaître
et ne pas mettre tous nos œufs dans le
même panier donc ça peut être produit en
France quand c'est produit en France que
ce soit en situation normale ou en
situation de crise vous avez à priori
accès
à la production quand c'est produit en
Europe et vous pouvez même recourir à
des outils un peu
je dirais
descendants pour sécuriser l'accès à la
production on a fait des réquisitions
mais vous pouvez réquisitionner ce qui
produit sur votre sol difficile d'aller
réquisitionner un truc qui produit aux
États-Unis ou en Allemagne ensuite
lorsque c'est dans des pays de l'Union
européenne vous avez quand même un
minimum de règles du jeu qui se mettent
assez vite en place et qui permettent
d'avoir des approvisionnements et puis
plus vous vous éloignez plus il faut se
poser la question d'avoir un double un
triple un quadruple approvisionnement
pour faire face à la fois à des risques
qui peuvent être génériques et arriver
donc une usine qui brûle un qui a un
conflit géopolitique ou internes majeur
et qui doit fermer ses frontières enfin
des choses qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'usine en question mais qui peut rendre
l'usine et d'accessible ou une situation
de pandémie et de tension qui font que
le la production va dire d'abord aux
usages domestiques avant d'aller à
d'autres usages et lorsque les quantités
de médicaments consommés s'envolent
comme on l'a constaté notamment
pendant la pandémie du covid
sur tout ce qui était
comment dire médicament qui permettait
d'être intubé voilà
confortablement en tant que possible on
a multiplié par 10 de mémoire la
consommation je vous avais mieux les
chiffres que moi effectivement là on
n'avait pas l'appareil de production
pour faire face donc c'est ce qui avait
la production qui était servie en privé
en priorité donc je pense qu'il faut
avoir une logique de sécurisation des
chaînes de valeur et de regarder qui
produit quoi ou et comment on sécurise
à minima de pas avoir une seule source
pour un type de médicaments dont les
usages sont
transversaux à trop de maladies ça c'est
assez clair deuxième élément avoir des
capacités de production à plat on l'a
vécu dans d'autres sujets c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce qu'on met sous cocon ou
qu'est-ce qu'on sait déplacer dans une
usine c'est un des une des réflexions
qu'on a eu avec Sanofi de se dire on a
un site de production de vaccin qui
fonctionne en temps normal et puis on a
un mode qui est un mode crise où on
pousse la production de vaccin classique
et on démarre autre chose et on sait
qu'on est capable de faire de la
dynovirus de l'ARN de la protéine
désactivée etc mais voilà on a les cuves
la taille les équipes parce que dans une
production de médicaments le poids
réellement critique c'est quand même les
ressources et les compétences passer à
parfois les matériaux parce que ça prend
du temps de qualifier une usine et c'est
les ressources et les compétences pour
être capable de produire dans l'usine
donc est-ce qu'on sait mettre en place
des systèmes de crise comme ça je pense
que c'est une réflexion intéressante
d'avoir le mode normal et le mode crise
et là on peut contractualiser avec
certains certains industriels le
troisième chose c'est en termes de
pilotage
en termes de pilotage d'abord le mode
Task Force fonctionne bien la teste ça
elle a eu une vraie valeur ajoutée et au
plan français et au plan Robert je
rappelle qu'en fait cette tasse force a
quand même assez largement inspiré ce
qui s'est passé au niveau européen on a
été les premiers à la mettre en place et
elle a réussi à surmonter beaucoup de
d'enjeux mais enfin je veux dire si on
était sur la capsule en aluminium qui
bouche avant le bouchon en plastique et
voilà on est rentré dans un niveau de
détails de circuit de production d'un
vaccin qui était particulièrement
profond en appelant ici et là et
effectivement concrètement nos 280
composants pour savoir où on sourcés en
quelle quantité comment on pouvait
sécuriser est-ce qu'on pouvait basculer
sur un autre fournisseur alors qu'on
n'avait pas l'homologation c'était ça
qu'on avait donc ça ça fonctionne ce qui
veut dire que il y a probablement des
silos puisque si on sait mettre des
taxes et que ça fonctionne c'est que le
fonctionnement classique est un peu
pivoté donc oui je pense que c'est
l'idée sous-jacente qui nous avait
inspiré à l'époque l'idée d'une agence
de l'innovation en santé c'est d'avoir
une cohérence des décisions qui sont
prises dans les différents
composants de l'État au service d'une
vision donc si on se dit demain il faut
avoir de la bioproduction au service de
tel type de thérapie et bien le
quelqu'un dans le fonctionnement
étatique est vraiment
chargé de ça et capable de dire la
Direction Générale des Entreprises j'ai
besoin que vous me référenciez tous les
fournisseurs potentiels sur ce type de
composants dont j'ai besoin pour faire
ça que
[Musique]
à un moment il faut qu'on soit
conséquent dans notre politique
si dans d'autres pays vous allez vous
avez une discussion plus rapide avec
l'Autorité de régulation
une capacité à obtenir une mise sur le
marché qui va trois fois plus vite
des financements qui vous permettent de
pré-financer votre ligne proto et des
financements qui vous permettent de
financer votre ligne industrielle et des
investisseurs privés je parle là
d'argent privé qui connaissent par coeur
la matière et qui sont capables de vous
donner les bons conseils au bon moment
et de prendre des risques c'est plus
facile et vous êtes plus attiré par ces
marchés là que si vous êtes sur un
marché ou à chaque étape il faut que
vous soyez champion du monde du passage
de la haie
et ça c'est quand même une réalité que
nous renvoie certains
chercheurs et c'est d'autant plus
frustrant que nous avons une capacité à
produire de la recherche de qualité et à
former des gens de très haut niveau et
on l'a vu encore récemment et c'est pas
propre à la santé les grandes pointures
de l'intelligence artificielle elles
sont souvent formées en France par
exemple et pourtant ils sont dans des
entreprises très globalisées
épanouièrement en France
donc ça c'est un dernier point sur tout
ce qui est financement objectif
budgétaire
non pardon deux choses il faut que les
engagements et on est constamment dans
une tension entre le court terme et le
moyen terme le court terme c'est la
trajectoire budgétaire de l'année le
moyen terme c'est les engagements qu'on
pense sur des projets qui sont à 5 ans
parfois 10 ans et dans lequel on dit à
tel moment on se rendent rendez-vous et
on fera tel effet
telle bouger à tel moment on sera au
rendez-vous vous achètera tel moment en
acceptant de prendre des risques
on l'a fait avec la covid dans la covid
on a commandé des vaccins sans savoir
exactement quelle quantité de quelle
quantité on allait avoir besoin on était
dans une dans un monde de crise ou de
toute façon
les choix étaient réduits mais être
capable de prendre des décisions qui
comme ça crainte l'avenir
et qu'on les tienne me paraît être un
point essentiel et ça regle avec
l'histoire de la clause de sauvegarde
si je vous dis les règles du jeu au
départ
je sécurise à tout le moins c'est-à-dire
ceux qui veulent jouer connaissent les
règles du jeu si je change les règles du
jeu chaque année
ça devient très compliqué et les
Français ont une petite tendance à
changer un peu rapidement les règles du
jeu et ça c'est vraiment le le reproche
qui est vraiment été je pense le plus
récurrent enfin je parle sous le
contrôle de mon ancien directeur de
cabinet qui a eu la gentillesse de venir
supporter cette audition c'est vraiment
ce qui nous revenait de manière vous les
Français faudrait juste que vous
arrêtiez de changer les règles du jeu
parce qu'on sait pas si on fait un match
de foot un match de tennis ou un match
de basket et c'est quand même pas la
même chose et on est prêt à jouer mais
il faut qu'on connaisse les règles les
règles du jeu et par rapport à ça et ça
sera mon dernier propos qui sera
beaucoup plus général
sur les dépenses de santé si on revient
quand même à la question de la
prévention et de la juste prescription
il y a des moyens d'avoir un retour sur
investissement sur des sujets qui font
toute la différence
on le sait tous on a un prisme on est
concentré sur la prise en charge de
pathologies on n'est pas concentré sur
le maintien en santé de la population
française
oui par rapport aux propos que vous avez
tenues de précision vous nous avez dit
que effectivement vous aviez utilisé le
levier réquisition c'est comme la
question que je vous avais posée sur
finalement la création
enfin l'ouverture et la fermeture
d'entreprise vous m'avez donné un
chiffre global et vous êtes engagé
effectivement à pouvoir nous fournir le
chiffre sur le secteur qui nous
intéresse de la santé moi j'aimerais
bien que vous puissiez nous fournir
effectivement les réquisitions que vous
avez pu
faire c'est la première question la
deuxième question qu'on vous dit
effectivement il faut pas changer les
règles les règles du jeu en cours de
match si je puis dire ça paraît tout à
fait tout à fait logique et vous dites
il faut un peu accélérer parfois un
certain nombre de de processus de
dispositif mais en même temps il faut
faire toujours attention de ne pas
désarmer l'État c'est à dire que par
exemple quand vous mettez les
autorisations temporaires d'utilisation
pour un certain nombre de médicaments on
a vu aussi parce que les êtres humains
sont des êtres humains on a vu aussi que
ce qui était une bonne idée pour
effectivement répondre aux besoins des
patients et des patients et donc faire
en sorte qu'il est qu'il puisse qu'on
puisse lutter contre la maladie et ben
on a vu ce dispositif là permettent à
des à des grands labos notamment sur des
médicaments innovants d'imposer un prix
qui était
phénoménal et une fois qu'ils avaient
imposé un prix de traitement et bien
effectivement s'y proposer de millions
et qu'on arrivait à un million cinq on
était content enfin c'est complètement
inabordable et inapsorbable par la
Sécurité Sociale donc c'est pour ça que
je moi j'ai insisté sur les armes que se
donne l'état le gouvernement pour un
moment donné siffler la fin de la récré
si je puis m'exprimer
elle est mise au point le le produit est
presque enfin voilà il est il est
apporté clé en main il faut le produire
alors peut-être sur ça sur les prix
exorbitants
le modèle de la pharmacie c'est pas un
modèle industriel classique d'abord
parce que les coûts de développement
peuvent être exorbitants
ensuite parce que le marché accessible
peut-être tout petit c'est problème des
maladies orphelines en particulier c'est
à dire qu'à un moment si vous avez 500
millions d'euros de développement de
coût de recherche pour 100 personnes qui
sont porteurs de la maladie vous
retrouvez avec forcément des coûts qui
sont très très élevés des vraies
questions éthiques d'ailleurs
assez complexe
et donc la question c'est à un moment
peut-être que pour mais je le pose là
pour faire baisser finalement le prix du
médicament c'est qu'elle part on est
prêt à prendre dans ce cas là dans le
coût de la recherche et dans la prise de
risque de ne pas trouver
d'organiser des essais cliniques qui
mènent à rien ou qui malheureusement
ne marque pas d'avancer significative en
termes thérapeutique c'est peut-être ça
qui est une façon de de découpler le
coût de revient de production qui est
effectivement en règle générale enfin à
ces modeste dans des limites tout à fait
raisonnable et
le nombre de fois en a raté et le coup
qu'a coûté la fois on a réussi avec en
plus nous aussi sur sur la partie et ses
clinique des choses qu'on peut améliorer
moi je vous invite vraiment
typiquement sur les essais cliniques et
ça aussi ça coûte pas d'argent à
regarder ce que font par exemple un des
plus grands hôpital du monde et celui du
Texas
qui a toute une base qui permet
avec l'intelligence artificielle de
créer un fichier de patients
potentiellement pouvoir rentrer dans un
essai clinique en quelques jours là où
humainement vous devez reprendre les
dossiers individuellement à la main
regardez etc pour savoir s'il peut
rentrer dans les cycliniques ça vous
prend quatre mois il y a des bougies
comme ça sur lesquelles on gagnerait
vraiment à regarder pour effectivement
baisser tous ses coups et c'est pas des
coups on perd du temps c'est pas des
coûts on fait un cadeau aux industries
Pharma si ou en fait on se met au
meilleur état de l'art en termes de
santé et de conduite de la recherche de
la recherche clinique ça je pense qu'on
a vraiment des gains à prendre de ce de
ce côté là
sur
sur la sur le prix à la fin le président
du CEPS peut prendre une décision
unilatérale vous le savez
c'est une arme
ultime
et donc
ça peut fonctionner et même si à la fin
le but c'est l'accès des patients en
traitement et donc c'est pour ça que on
privilégie toujours la voie de l'accord
et vous savez bien que dans une
négociation enfin je sais pas à quel
point le président du CEPS est rentré
dans la conduite des négociations mais
vous jouez du carotte et du bâton en
permanence de la carotte et du bâton
c'est on peut faire un prix mais
attention je peux conclure une ligne
littéralement on peut t'adore mais
attention voilà et il est encore une
fois il est plutôt reconnu
internationalement que les négociateurs
français sont des gens
qualifiés et qui arrivent à des
résultats en tout cas satisfaisants au
regard de l'enjeu de d'utilisation des
des deniers publics mais effectivement
en fait cette complexité de quel prix on
donne
à l'empreinte à l'industrielle à une
politique de moyen terme à la création
d'un partenariat avec telle ou tel
industriel quel prix on donne à ça ce
qui est compliqué
merci beaucoup de toutes ces réponses et
de cet échange lors de l'audition assez
complet et donc je vais lever la séance
nous avons les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement donc
j'ai prévu les 5 minutes pour pouvoir y
accéder
et je lève la séance et puis nous avons
d'autres commissions en fin de journée
d'autres auditions
[Musique]